bonsoir monsieur merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france les attaques
contre les intérêts américains semblent
augmenter ces derniers mois pour quelles
raisons la raison est très simple la
hausse avait de 2003 à 2010 8 fin 2018
l'irak qui nous disposait pas et qui ne
dispose toujours pas des infrastructures
pour fonctionner au tant qu'etat
souverain a
ils étaient autant que keita
opérationnel parce qu'il y avait un
accord entre washington et téhéran pour
faire fonctionner cet état irradiant
autrement dit il y avait une concorde il
avait un parfum partenariat une
cogestion américaine iranienne pour
gérer le dossier irakien l'état irakien
l'homme possible et aération
on défend 2018 plus précisément le 26
décembre 2018 donald trump arrive à en
irak
il y a atterri sur la base est à la base
militaire al assad en irak et il fait
une déclaration en disant que la
présence américaine en irak vise à
surveiller les activités de la
république islamique de l'iran au moyen
orient
le lendemain c'était le cas où c'était
le choc c'était la panique pourquoi
parce que tout simplement par cette
déclaration donald trump a mis fin à
cette cogestion américano iranienne de
de ces irakiens est depuis fin 2010 8
jusqu'à aujourd'hui le pays fin l'irak
et vit dans le cas où dans votre
désordre c'est la guerre de tous contre
tous vous n'avez pas un gouvernement
stable vous avez un mouvement de
contestation très très fort vous avez
des des confrontations entre les
iraniens
les pro iranien et les américains il y à
des attaques réciproques les pro iranien
vise l'ambassade les aéroports les bases
militaires américains dans le pays les
forces armées américaines vie
les différentes milices irakiennes des
deux côtés delà de la frontière foire
frontières c'est-à-dire en irak et en
syrie
et voilà le contexte global dans lequel
on se trouve alors les ministres
responsables de ces attaques seraient
liées à l'appareil sécuritaire irakien
mais financé par l'iran
comment est ce possible ministre pro
iranienne prennent de l'ampleur on ira
écouter on n'ira que j'ai pas très très
bien entendu votre question alors si la
question c'est sur les milices pro
iranienne en irak c'est que vous
aujourd'hui on n'ira que vous avez trois
catégories du ministre vous avez des
milices nationalistes représentées
incarné par moqtada sadr vous avez les
milices de la match a incarné par elle
pour l'assistanat et vous avez des
milices pro iranienne a représenté
surtout par kataëb hezbollah les les
attaques contre les intérêts américains
en irak sont souvent à 99 points 98 %
conduit par cette faction c'est ce
groupe qui s'appellera kh2 les kataëb
hezbollah
alors donc c'est pourquoi les états unis
d'amérique vise nous pas les milices
nationaliste nous pas les milices de la
marche arrière mais plutôt des milices
pro iranien l'état irakien dénoncé en
tout cas une violation grave de la
souveraineté irakienne est ce que vous
comprenez cette réaction est ce que
c'est le cas nous allons absolument pas
à vous savez on n'ira que c'est qu'on
déclare officiellement est ce que l'on
fait dans les coulisses ce sont deux
choses complètement radicalement
différente
ces attaques
contre les milices pro iranienne ne
peuvent être produisent sans la
coordination dans les coulisses avec les
autorités irakiennes
mons perf à 15 me et bien évidemment
dans l'obligation sous voies dans le
rôle de condamner aux tankers premier
ministre ces attaques mais en réalité on
sait très bien qu'il y a un partenariat
très fort entre le le gouvernement
régional du kurdistan le gouvernement de
15 me et les forces américaines sur le
sol irakien
c'est grâce à cette coordination que les
états unis d'amérique peuvent viser ces
milices pro iranienne donc non je ne
suis pas étonné lors c'est jean poncet
déclaration qui condamne ces attaques
mais ce qui se passe ce qui m'intéresse
moi c'est ce qui se passe dans les
coulisses et nous passent une telle
déclaration
et qu'est ce qui se passe alors dans les
coulisses jusqu'où ça peut aller
ces tensions c'est très simple a
cependant que nous sommes en train de
dialoguer ensemble vous et moi il y à
des négociations a à la fois à bagdad et
à erbil entre les américains et les
iraniens il ya il y a eu un processus de
négociation donnant 30 à fin 2010 8
roues avec cette cogestion avec cette
concorde avec l'arrivée de joe biden à
la maison blanche au pouvoir aux états
unis d'amérique
le président américain a la volonté à la
volonté de remettre en place à cette
cogestion parce qu'il sait très bien
lui-même il s'est rendu en irak 24 x 24
x 1
pendant ces différents montas il connaît
parfaitement le terrain irakien il
connaît chaque communauté chaque acteur
il connaît les élites iraq and il
connaît les institutions de cet état qui
n'est plus opérationnel et il sait très
bien pour stabiliser l'eau minimum pour
à sécuriser l'eau minimum ira pour
développer le minimum possible soap et
là il faut absolument faire un accord
avec la république islamique de l'iran
sans lequel le pays sera vraiment dans
le chaos absolu
voir la guerre de tout le monde
comportement c'est à dire la guerre
civile et pour cela je byden souhaite
remettre en place cette cogestion
seulement ils les américains et les
iraniens à r'wil et à bagdad à ce
jusqu'à aujourd'hui n'arrive pas à
trouver une formule et parce qu'ils sont
à prendre dans le processus engagé dans
ce processus de négociation ils
l'envoient réciproquement des messages
par des requêtes par des attaques par
des prises en otage par des missiles et
donc toutes ces opérations là la seule
leçon à retenir c'est que et il monte en
puissance pour peser sur la négociation
en cours à erbil et avec des mercis adel
bat kahone directeur du centre français
de recherche irak d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur arte france